7.3 billion dollars that's how much  Tesla is investing in its new China  Factory it would be Shanghai's biggest  foreign manufacturing project ever and  it's a coup for Tesla many foreign car  makers export into China and pay tariffs  which is trickier these days with the  trade dispute Tesla also believes China  is the perfect market it's very  important that the world transitioned to  sustainable transport and sustainable  energy generation so solar battery  storage and electric vehicles and China  has been a world leader in that  transition so we look forward to helping  helping accelerate that transition along  with other electric car companies in  China  Tesla needs the good news to 2018 was a  difficult year with a regulator  crackdown questions over leadership and  missed production goals